there's no reason why you can't have the
same level of intimacy with a transman
probably some more fun with a courtesy
reach
around yeah I'm going to be honest with
you I I take that point see it'd be nice
to have someone down there who knows
what they're doing but like home court
advantage yeah exactly exactly you know
you know so is that is the home court
advantage enough for you to move to
agree absolutely [__] not but what
about the argument that it could be more
fun I mean you're kind of used to the
same thing right if you've never been
with a trans woman you you're kind of
getting stale in that dating Arena you
know cuz dating is kind of like Curry
you experiment a bit with what you like
and you think could I TR I'll try this
and I try this and then you just sit on
Al larm sag and that's what you like and
that's what you have every time right